[Music]
debbie is in boise idaho
hi debbie welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up i've got a few questions
well one is i'm trying i've tried your
program for probably five or six years
now
trying to get my husband on board i
can't get him to look at a budget
or even sit down and look at the ability
that he's a spender
uh he's the free spirit and i'm the um
nerd
um so that's the first thing and just
i've done things like refinance the
house
paid out saved money and paid off credit
cards and
gotten rid of them all except for a
couple and then he's created more
um so i feel like i'm just going
backwards how old is how old is he
he's gonna be 60 and i'm 55.
how long y'all been married 24 years
you know i honestly expected you to say
he was 26
because he's acting like a child
well i know and it's almost caused a
divorce at one point um
i can imagine thousand dollar boat
that he didn't come with me a 50
000 boat that he did not consult you on
yep we paid for it with our credit
everything's credit
um and that's what's concerning me is
he's self-employed
and his income he's not as physical as
he used to be
so our income is decreasing so i'm
stressed trying to get rid of the bills
because
i know we're getting older and i'm just
not
able to get rid of them when i turn
around and
create another card i'll pay one off and
he'll create another debbie this is not
a money problem this is a marriage
problem
a big marriage problem the fact that
he's not consulting with you
listening to you considering what's
important to you this is
he does not value you by his actions
right now and that is a
major problem
yeah this is not just about you're
trying to pay off bills
go ahead honey you can't dig out of the
hole
i mean you can't fill up the whole
faster and he can dig it out no uh-uh
yeah and it doesn't it doesn't matter
how quick you you pay it off if he
continues to do this
and the level of disrespect you must
feel when he does
it's not again it's not just about the
spending man yeah the level of
disrespect
that he should have even gone so far as
to not pay some bills so that he
couldn't get more credit
on certain bills because i was trying to
pay off other bills
like if you you're working real hard not
to address the real issue aren't you
yeah yeah i guess so
okay are you do you guys happen to
attend a church
um i'm trying to but i can't get him on
board with that either
yeah okay so here's what you need to do
hon okay this is a lot more than christy
and i can fix
in a radio call this is 24 years
of misbehavior and
he's your husband i i'm his age
he's misbehaving if one of my friends
was treating his wife this way
i would be up in his grill
if one of my closest buddies and i got i
got about 10 or 15 guys i run with
pretty tight
and if one of those guys was acting the
reason i run tight with them is they
don't treat their wives this way
um and i can tell you this if i treated
sharon ramsey this way
i'd have to be dealing with one mad
hillbilly woman after about the first
round it wouldn't have lasted 24 years
lasted 24 minutes
right and that's why i think you know
do you work debbie i do matter of fact
um i'm
well he's self-employed uh and i'm
self-employed realtor
i we just pulled our business of 12
years uh and moved to a different state
and bought it you know sold our house
that was worth more and bought and to
reduce that
let me let me cycle back the reason i
was asking where you if you
were in church was not a a spiritual
statement i'm trying to find somewhere
you can get community
to get get somebody to talk with him
but uh so what you need to do is you
need to find a good
faith-based marriage counselor
as soon as possible you're 20 years
late coming to that meeting right he's
not going to do that either
but you go anyway because you need
someone
long form not a radio answer to begin to
help you
formulate conversations with him because
you're either going to live a
miserable broke stress-filled life for
the next
24 years or you're going to force his
hand
on this he's going to change or it's
going to end
one of the two things is going to happen
here yeah and you the problem is
is you're really late and it's going to
be very hard to get him to hear
because he's never had to hear you've
cried wolf so many times you've dug him
out so many times
i don't know if he's going to hear it or
not but you need to get someone to teach
you
how crazy you're being treated this is
cray cray
it's wrong yeah no and the reason i
asked if she worked because i thought
well let me dig into this is there
does he think because he makes the money
no that he can do whatever it does it
doesn't matter why but you
you have to address the real issue this
is not just a financial issue
this is a lack of respect this is a lack
of value this is a lack of communication
it y'all are not a marriage you're not a
partnership you're not
the things that make a marriage y'all
don't have trust
communication mutual respect you don't
have those things
you may have a marriage certificate but
you don't have those things and so a
counselor can help you
figure out what this looks like for you
what actions you can begin to speak to
him in a way that maybe
he can hear you for the first time and
give your marriage a shot
because this is not going in the good
direction hun
um i'm sorry i'm sorry sorry you're
dealing with it yeah that
it honestly makes me mad there is not a
financial technique in the world that
will fix
this situation